uh yeah first I wanted to thank Sean
again for organizing this and also Nick
for being the angel
I'm giving us an opportunity
it's only intellectual heroes a lot of
people that I hope to keep contact with
I think for me the most valuable part of
the conference I think it's time I have
made contact with a lot of people that I
can have discourse with in the future
particularly as I try to write this book
on naturalism and theology and I will
call it you at some point I guess the
highlights for me in the meeting of
course the discussion of free will and
that's something that I thought I read a
lot about and I guess I'm gratified that
people seem to agree that it is a black
hole of with oh and that's a black hole
of philosophy I continue to disagree
with Dan that if we tell people they
don't have free will that society will
fall apart I mean that arguments are
made for retaining religion and things
like that but but it hasn't happened in
countries like Fiona Naevia so I need to
be convinced by more than just
performance on whether you cheat on
whether via free will the discussion of
entailment I thought was enlightening to
me Stephens presentation of that how
higher levels can derive from lower
levels I remain unconvinced that there
was any qualitatively new phenomena that
are not until both laws of physics but
you know I haven't seen anything I think
a period just seems impossible huh I
appreciated Maximus discussion
particularly at the end on scientism and
ways of knowing you know it was a
remarkable clarity I thought and I would
have liked to discuss it longer one of
the questions I have which is on answer
in this meeting is are there other ways
of knowing besides saw not through
science is mathematics a form of science
are all questions about the universe
only resolvable through empirical
observation and I am open on that
question now I hope to discuss it maybe
somewhere with Dan and I Drive back to
Boston the questions that are unresolved
to me first of all about what naturalism
is that's sharing still at this point
we've had diverse definitions I don't
think we could move it forward until we
know what it is or at least we have a
definition that we all agree on but I
think Owen made the point that he
doesn't think that we've moved
naturalism forward much here and I think
he's right but I don't think that this
is the kind of venue to move naturalism
for I kind of the venue to move
naturalism for is in the political realm
because you dispel superstition through
improving the lots of people in the
world so that they don't have to turn a
superstition some right I mean the best
thing I can say to do to move Nationals
and forties to vote for a bomb things I
wish we had discussed more are the
concept of morality and moral
responsibility do they have any meaning
is what is there a real meaning to being
responsible versus morally responsible
and I hear diverse opinions about that
I'm not sure how I feel about well
actually I do I don't think that people
are morally responsible I think they're
responsible in a technical sense but
that's all the other ways of knowing
question I've mentioned that's something
I'm extremely interested in I'll
probably correspond with some review
about this is of course used to enable
theism religious people say faith is
another way of knowing and we have all
these other ways of knowing they're
efficacious like in art literature music
so why not through revelation as well
and I have to answer this question in my
book and I'm not sure yet how to do it
I wish we had talked more about the
nature of reality what do we mean by
reality Stephen said everything is real
including God they're only in a sense
that Santa Claus is true and I'm not
quite sure yeah I'm not sure everybody
met but except if an idea has a reality
which to me is different from what I
conceive does a reality before where I
changed my mind about and to me this is
a substantial change is this based on
what Shawn and Dan other people said I
wrote on my website this morning that I
did not think that the formal discipline
of the philosophy of science had any
contribution to make to moving science
forward' discussing this morning I
realize now that that's not true and I
am going to correct myself of
that and I will correct myself in that I
hope with Dan based on his kitchen free
world also correct himself by saying
that now he agrees that free will is
equivalent to morally competent volition
so I'll make a deal with him that all
renege if he'll admit that somewhere in
France oh oh yeah that's right sick but
people might want to edit it out because
politically expedient okay where I talk
about you know I think the you or I
would still disagree what we mean by
that but anyway that's the last point I
wanted to make and I thank everybody for
talking to me and Shawn and Nick for
helping arrange the whole thing
you